the Battleground in what is threatening
to become a long-running and bitter
dispute hospitals and patients across
England bracing themselves for months of
disruption unless a resolution can be
found
but from the language being used by the
Royal College of Nursing and the
government an immediate breakthrough is
looking extremely unlikely our nurses
have rejected it its short-term measures
it plugs the Gap that's what they've
said and in fact they've found that it
was an insulting offer to put a bonus a
bonus on the table and then take it off
them again next year and find themselves
back in a place where they can't pay
their bills Health secretary Steve
Barkley has written to the RCN
expressing his disappointment
emphasizing unison's acceptance of the
offer he said I'm also both disappointed
and concerned that the Royal College of
Nursing has chosen to announce 48 Hours
of continuous strike action without
consultation of other staff Council
unions all waiting for the full staff
Council consultation to complete he goes
on to say the decision to refuse at this
stage any exemptions for even the most
urgent and life threatening treatment
during this action will I fear put
patience at risk
the RCN says some parts of the offer
especially around Staffing legislation
and structure are encouraging but
ultimately it wants more money for its
nurses the government says there is none
available this is a very very reasonable
offer it's fair to it's fair to NHS
workers it's fair to other public sector
workers and is fair to the taxpayer
Steve Barkley has said that his door is
always open so long as in particular
answer the preconditions or strikes
taking place you know we are willing to
talk this strike will be escalated no
derogations and for the first time no
cover for intensive care they're just
aren't circumstances in which I'm going
to sit on your program and say I think
it's right to remove cover for emergency
care for Cancer Care I think that would
be the wrong thing to do
and that urgency becomes more acute with
the possibility of coordinated strike
action between junior doctors and nurses
I've just been speaking to the CEO of a
large NHS Hospital trust and he told me
that any coordinated action between
junior doctors and nurses would
effectively shut his Hospital down he
wouldn't be able to offer any patient
services except perhaps keep open the
doors to his emergency department but he
went on to say he didn't think it would
come to this because all sides involved
in this dispute know exactly what sort
of impact any coordinated action would
have on patients he said it was the
ultimate threat
a threat everyone hopes can be averted
and this conflict finally settled oh
she's Joshy Sky News